we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
funny kind of interesting but also a
prescient voicemail this is from a
foreigner who just doesn't understand
how trump is able to get away with lies
all the time take a listen hey David
this is Andre calling from good for
Germany yes I've got a question could
you please explain to me why the media
Barack Obama Joe Biden and the rest of
the Democratic Party do not rip Trump
apart for the BS and the lies he keeps
telling on a daily basis I mean any of
these lies and false allegations which
Trump has been spreading over the last
couple of weeks would have been
political suicide in Germany yes I mean
to me the media and the Democrats they
seem like victims that are too afraid to
stand up against a bully what do you
think about that yeah so listen I
understand the total bewilderment around
the world at what is going on from
bizzle laughingstock and yet he doesn't
seem to sort of suffer the consequences
this is only partially because of
Democrats and it's only partially
because of the media I've talked before
about how when Trump lies at a press
briefing and he gets called out on the
lie he will tell three more lies and
then move on to the next reporter and
it's very hard to control that or he
will simply end the press briefing early
and these things in the United States
are not proving to be political suicide
why because you have such a partisan
environment that half the country
doesn't care or half the country seized
from leaving early from a press briefing
as a sign of power or they simply
believe everything he says we have such
a broken critical critical thinking has
broken in the United States and so I get
it people you know my family from
Argentina my family that lives in France
my family that lives in Israel they see
what's going on in this what how are
people not just calling Trump out and
how is it not hurting him politically
you have to understand the degree of
ignorance and partisanship that exists
in the United States to really
understand the answer to that and it is
very very ugly on the bonus show
we will talk about George Floyd we will
talk about Kelly Lafleur we will talk
about Ron de santis and much much more
get instant access to the bonus show at
join pakman.com very much look forward
to speaking to you then